here it is right yeah it has different
kind of price let's talk about these
pipelines and um
this accusation of sabotage Ukraine
coming out saying Russia have done it
talk to me about the geography of this
and How likely it is that Russia are
responsible for the damage yeah the
Nordstrom on Nordstrom two pipelines as
you can see follow almost the same path
except
um where there's a sort of Kink where
the explosions actually occurred and
there may be two of them maybe in three
that's the only place where they're
different that's actually quite deep
water uh the Baltic goes from about 50
meters to about 500 meters deep and it's
pretty deep east of Bonham Island and
these explosions were at least
equivalent to 200 250 pounds of TNT each
so they're quite big only a very
professional organization could do this
only a big country could do it
and the effect of course is they're not
they're not pumping gas at the moment
but they're full of gas because empty
pipelines have to have gas in them and
the gas that's now going off into the
Baltic will actually last maybe about a
week and it may or may not cause an
ecological disaster the the only
incredible
culprit is Russia it's in nobody else's
interests and Russia is I'm sure is
sending a message that the Baltic
actually that these pipelines will not
work again you can't expect any more gas
in Europe from from us and increasingly
importantly this is the the red line is
the line of the Baltic pipe which was
inaugurated yesterday just as these uh
uh explosions occurred and you can see
the Baltic pipe passes over uh the area
of North stream one and Nordstrom too
and I'm sure that the message here is
that all gas pipelines in the Baltic may
now be vulnerable and the Europeans
better realize that this is typical
Putin psychology frighten everybody just
increase the pressure make people
frightened of him
um and I think as we've been saying
since the beginning of this crisis this
crisis has escalation built into it and
now I think the crisis come to the
Baltic we will now see a lot of NATO
activity I think protecting pipelines
and all the undersea cables the internet
cables which are huge and we've been
worrying about this for years now it
started to happen my view is that this
week the war in Ukraine has come to the
Baltic
let's talk about what is happening in
Ukraine because of course we're looking
here that's where President Putin wants
us to look but actually we need to keep
an eye on what's going on in the ground
in Ukraine can you bring us up to date
with what's happening yes I mean this is
the most important area of the area of
kharkiv and the northern part of the
donbass the Russians are making progress
of back much this is the Wagner group
they're pushing it back I don't know why
because it has no relationship to
anything else and if they're successful
in taking back mud they may not be it
won't do them any good if the ukrainians
are actually doing well on their
Northern flanks so there's there's a
sort of incoherence about that the
Russians really should worry about
what's happening at Lyman and svatori
because the Russians have got a line
from troyce go right down to criminal
and svatovi is the important part of
that now Lyman is the sort of Southern
base of all of that defensive line which
the Russians are Hulk trying to hold and
already the ukrainians in the last 72
hours have got around the back of them
and
yam pill and there's only about 10
kilometers in between those two places
and those 10 kilometers contain lots of
reservoirs a whole line of reservoirs so
the Russians are getting surrounded if
they don't get out of alignment soon
they will be trapped and they already
will find it difficult to get the heavy
equipment out because there's an awful
lot of water between Lyman and the area
to the east which is is their own as it
were safer territory things are
happening very quickly in lineman if the
Russians lose that as most of us expect
them to do in the next 24 48 hours then
they're positioned north of that in
cremina and svatovay will actually be
weakened in their position south of it
will be much much weaker